security is tight in washington this
morning ahead of a highly anticipated
rally temporary fencing is up again
around the u.s capitol and the national
guard is on standby tomorrow's rally is
in support of the people accused of
assaulting the capitol on january 6.
chris vancleave is on capitol hill chris
good morning
good morning even if this is all just an
abundance of caution this will be the
biggest test of security in the d.c area
since january 6. you can see the fence
is up around the capitol if you look up
here you're going to see a brand new
high-tech hd camera system on loan from
the army and as the day goes on the
police presence the visible police
presence around the capitol is only
going to ramp up that's because there's
some chatter that has police concern not
only about tomorrow but also about later
today
local and federal police are on high
alert this morning across washington d.c
an estimated 700 far right demonstrators
are expected to gather outside the
capitol saturday in a rally to support
those who rioted on january 6. according
to an intelligence bulletin obtained by
cbs news the department of homeland
security is aware of a small number of
recent online threats of violence
connected to the rally and found online
discussions encouraging violence the day
before according to the bulletin social
media users discussed storming the
capitol the night before the rally and
other references to violence included
using the rally to target jewish
institutions elected officials and
liberal churches but rally organizer
matt brainard a former trump campaign
staffer says the event will be peaceful
the capitol police know that we are no
threat
this is a theater to deter people from
attending his group look ahead america
alleges the more than 600 people facing
criminal charges for the january 6th
insurrection have been singled out for
their political views former president
trump who is not expected to attend said
in a statement the people arrested in
connection with january 6 are being
persecuted so unfairly you certainly
can't ignore any chatter thomas o'connor
was an fbi agent for 23 years on the
joint terrorism task force he says law
enforcement must over prepare what i'm
most worried about and still worry about
is the threat that we do not know about
that's the threat that's going to get by
the rally organizers have similar
protests planned at state capitals
across the country this weekend and next
weekend several congressional offices
have encouraged their staff to work from
home today gail
all right got it chris thank you